hello I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
and with the imminent arrival of the
next Red Dead game we thought it only
apps to go back and look at Red Dead
Redemption storyline in less than three
minutes so let's do this before Red Dead
Redemption begins John Marston was a
successful thief murderer and all-round
bad guy as part of a gang led by Dutch
van der Linde John Marston Bill
Williamson and Xavier escuela made up
the bulk of the outlaws but there was
also another member who went by the name
Abigail she for want of a better term
was a traveling prostitute which was a
regular occurrence back in the Wild West
days when John and Abigail got a little
bit too intimate leading to Abigail's
pregnancy John began to yearn for a way
to leave the criminal life behind and to
one day be an honorable man and a loving
father he asks Abigail to marry him at
gunpoint no less and begins to
mastermind their escape 13 years later
John is left for dead after a botched
bank robbery and takes his opportunity
to leave the gang along with Abigail and
their son Jack three years later in 1911
John is approached by Edgar Ross a
government official who offers him
redemption for his previous exploits
Ross has taken Abigail and Jack into
custody and demands John kills his old
gang mates Xavier squalor Bill
Williamson and leader Dutch van der
Linde oh Mr Marston your wife and so
nerd' are doing well let's both try to
ensure things to stay that way Bill
Williamson is finally killed after
running away from master new multiple
times Xavier escuela is either killed
off sent to prison following an assault
on a fort and Dutch van der Linde meets
his demise after giving an exceptional
monologue and leaping from a snowy
mounting once all his former gang mates
are in the ground or behind bars
Edgar Ross keeps his word and frees
Abigail and Jack it looks like our story
ends in happiness but sadly your heart
is about to be ripped out as Edgar Ross
decides to double-cross John by gunning
him down on
luckily John has already got a B and
Jack on horseback and sent them away but
when they return
John is no longer of this world after
being buried by his loving wife and son
we then rejoined the story three years
later playing as John son Jack Abigail
has also passed at this point leaving
jack all on his own Jack decides to find
out the truth about his father's death
and begins to search for his killer Jack
finally tracks down Edgar Ross who is
unrepentant about his axe three years
earlier Ross and Jack guild to the death
which have cost Jack wins Jack continues
his father's good deeds and
reestablishes the master NIM in the
final days of the Wild West please do as
a favor and press the like button and
maybe even subscribe to our content we
hope that helps to refresh your memory
about Red Dead Redemption
I've been Adam from PlayStation granade
see you next time partner such a bad
joke